Great. Well, welcome. Today we're
gonna continue talking about vaccines.
So we started on this topic on Tuesday,
particularly emphasizing smallpox and kind
of the history of vaccine development,
but then also emphasizing
in the case of smallpox,
how even after the scientific
discovery was made, it took many,
many decades for people to be able to
produce the vaccine in large enough
quantities and distributed so that you
could think about making an impact on, uh,
on global prevalence of the disease and
want to talk about that same concept,
uh, today in terms of polio,
which is a vaccine that is, uh,
both,
um,
made and manufactured in a different
way than the smallpox vaccine.
And that will lead us into a discussion
of sort of modern methods and sort of
the spectrum of methods that are
available now for vaccine development.
The other thing that I want to do
today is try to tie this discussion on
vaccines a little bit more closely with
what we talked about last week in terms
of,
uh,
of what happens inside your body when
you receive a vaccine or when you're
exposed to an antigen and how,
uh,
how the immune system
actually responds to that.
And so the question is what happens after
a vaccine is introduced into the body?
And I want to spend some time
on that till we talk about,
before we talk about development of,
of the polio vaccine.
And so here I've just picked a
couple of the pictures that, uh,
that I showed you last time when we were
talking about cell communication in the
immune system, uh, because the,
what happens after the vaccine is
introduced into your body is that a,
is that it initiated cellular events and
cells share signals with each other and
that leads to activation of
a specific cell population.
If we're thinking about a vaccine
that produces antibodies, for example,
that leads to activation of B cells,
immature B cells,
which do two things.
They both proliferate increase
in number and they differentiate,
they differentiate from immature B
cells into antibody producing cells.
And so let me, uh, let me go back to
what we talked about last week and,
and illustrate that a
little bit more closely.
So one of the things that happens is
that certain cells within your body
process, the vaccine or the
Antigen, and we talked about that,
we talked about host's cells that are
perhaps infected with a virus displaying
pieces of that virus,
antigenic pieces of that virus in the
context of a surface receptor called MHC
one and presenting that and other cells
in the immune system recognizing that
this is,
this is a foreign molecule,
but it's being presented in
the context of a self cell,
right? So because it has
MHC one your MHC one on it,
this t cell recognizes that
it's one of your cells,
but it has a foreign antigen
associated with it. In this case,
it might be a piece of a virus that's
replicating inside this cell, right?
And so that's antigen presentation to
this population of cells called cytotoxic
t cells, cytotoxic t cells, t sub c,
a subset of the class of t
cells in the immune system.
They become activated and they produce
eventually mature cytotoxic t cells in
large numbers.
And these cells can now kill cells
that have the correct signature.
And the signature is MHC one with this
foreign antigen associated with it.
Right now for antibody production,
it is still a t cell that recognizes
the antigen presenting cell.
But this antigen presenting cell is
more likely a professional antigen
presenting cell or a subset of cells of
your immune system that are specialized
in ingesting foreign
particles and displaying their
contents to the rest of the
immune system.
And so the classes of t cells,
macrophages and natural killer
cells, these are uh, and uh, uh,
uh, class of cells that's particularly
important, uh, called dendritic cells.
They might ingest extra cellular antigen,
presented pieces of it on their cell
surface in the context of MHC to
another subset of t cells called t
helper cells will recognize that signal
by direct contact with it and they
will become activated and proliferate.
Now these th cells,
helper t cells go on to stimulate B cells
and it's these B cells that become the
mature antibody producing cells that make
quantities of an antibody that fill up
in your body,
but,
and the antibody that they stimulate is
antibody that's specific to this antigen
that was presented earlier,
right? So now I recognize, well,
you should recognize that this is a
very simplified view of a highly complex
network of interactions that takes place.
If you go on to study more about
immunology, which I know most of you will,
you will recognize that I'm,
this is just the simplest level
of one of the most complex, uh,
systems, uh, within our body.
And it has to be complex because we're
asking the immune system to be able to
respond to every potential foreign
pathogen that we come into contact with.
And it does that through a complex
set of sort of cellular interactions.
And it turns out also gene rearrangements,
if you go further to study that.
So this is just a,
this is a highly simplified view and
what I want you to remember is that
specific subpopulations
of cells get activated.
The activation results
in a specific response.
In this case here,
you're generating host's cells,
cytotoxic t cells that can
kill only very specific cells,
cells that are expressing
this foreign antigen.
And in the case of the helper cells,
they stimulate a specific population
of B cells to mature into antibody
producing cells.
And that antibody is generated against
the antigen that stimulated it.
All right? Um, so if,
if we just thought about
that second part of it,
just the antibody
generation or the humoral,
what we called last time last week,
the humoral immune response,
the immune response.
That's ssociate with generation of
antibodies in the blood and other fluids.
And we looked at the
kinetics of this response.
What happens in your body after
you're exposed to an antigen?
So this is a time course here.
The scale is in days.
So this is several months and this,
uh,
this logarithmic scale on the y axis,
it represents antibody concentration.
And now we're not thinking about total
antibody concentration because you
already have a lot of antibodies
circulating within your blood and in your
fluids.
We're thinking about the particular
antibody that binds to this antigen that
you're exposed to.
And I'm using here Antigen interchangeably
with vaccine for our purposes today,
right?
So the antigen we're thinking about is a
vaccine particularly designed to elicit
an immune response against the pathogen.
So you introduce that antigen
into a person, into me,
for example,
and there's a lag period where if
I was just looking for antibodies,
nothing happens for a while.
And at some point, maybe, uh,
maybe a week later,
four to eight days later,
you start to see antibody levels rise.
And, uh, again, this,
these are antibodies that are specific
to that Antigen or vaccine that we
introduced. Those levels would reach
a plateau after some period of time,
maybe after a couple of weeks, and
then they would begin to decline again.
Right now,
if I was a person that was designing a
vaccine and I noticed that this was the
response that it got,
the antibodies were produced,
they reached some intermediate level,
they started to fall. I would say, well,
I haven't stimulated the
immune system enough.
Let me reboost let me give
another dose of Antigen.
And if you did that,
what would happen is you
would see antibody levels
rise even more sharply than
before.
The response to the second exposure to
an antigen is different in a couple of
ways.
One is there's no lag period.
Notice that antibody levels start rising
right away after the second exposure
and and that rate of rise is steeper,
so they antibody levels go up more
rapidly and they reach a higher level.
Now this is just a typical response.
You might,
you could probably find some antigens
that don't follow exactly this behavior,
but in general,
this is the kind of behavior you would
see on first exposure to an antigen or
vaccine called the primary exposure and
on subsequent exposure to an antigen or
vaccine called the boost.
Right? So if this was tetanus,
you got this tetanus
vaccine when you were young,
you get a boost every five or 10 years
because your antibody levels are starting
to fall right
now.
Just what this diagram also shows you is
that that response is specific to that
particular antigen.
It's not just that your whole immune
system gets revved up and it's going to
respond more rapidly to any
antigen it's exposed to.
Because if we did the experiment
where on this booster,
we included not only the initial
antigen but some unrelated antigen,
the response to the unrelated antigen
called be here looks like a primary
response, right? There's a lag phase.
There's a slow rise to an
intermediate level of antibody, right?
And so every time you're exposed
to a new vaccine or a new antigen,
you go through this, this, uh,
this primary response before
you have the secondary response.
Does that make sense? Kate?
Did you have a question?
Secondary volume?
So, so I'm not sure I understand
the question. So the question is,
if you're naturally exposed to antigen,
wouldn't this happen anyway? Yeah. So,
so for example, you get exposed
to it. Before there was a vaccine,
you're brother and sister had chicken pox.
And so you got exposed to chicken pox.
Naturally through your contact with them,
you would have this initial response.
Now that initial response might be too
slow to prevent you from getting chicken
pox.
Right?
You just start with
secondary
secondary response.
Yeah. So, so, so you're
asking if, for example,
why do you need a booster of tetanus?
Because if I get exposed to tetanus,
wouldn't I have this rapid response?
And the answer is yes, you would.
The question is, would, would that
response, even though it's much faster,
be fast enough to protect you from the
initial exposure to tetanus that you got
and probably it wouldn't, you'd
probably get a little bit sick anyway,
but recover. Right? So, so that's
a really good question. And,
and I'm talking in terms of
generalities here, uh, but,
but the specifics matter and that's
why every development of every specific
vaccine turns out to be different because
they don't all follow exactly this
kind of time course.
Some,
like the smallpox vaccine on an on one
on one exposure generates a very high
response that lasts for many years.
So you don't need a boost, right?
And others generate a weaker
response that does require boosting.
So there's no absolutes
about this, right? This is,
this is a general response where all
the features can be different with
different, uh, pathogens. Did
that answer your question?
So why the leg phase? Why the
lag phase at the beginning? Well,
because it takes some time
for these cellular events
that I mentioned earlier to
happen, right? The Antigen has to
be presented to helper t cells.
Those helper t cells have to stimulate
a B cell population to both proliferate
and differentiate.
So this is a picture I showed you before,
and you can imagine that even when this
immature B cell gets the signal, uh,
you're now, now's the time you need
to turn on antibody production.
That it takes some time
for it to both proliferate,
to make a cells and for those cells to
mature to the point where they become,
uh, where they become what
are called plasma cells,
which are antibody producing factories.
Take some time for that to happen. Now,
why is the time less on second exposure?
Because on second exposure,
there's another population of cells that
I haven't mentioned before that remain
after the primary exposure.
And those are called memory cells.
They're down here.
So not all of the B cells
that are stimulated become
plasma cells are antibody
secreting cells. Some of them
become what are called memory cells.
And these are cells that
recognize a particular antigen.
They're ready to
differentiate into antibody,
they're ready to rapidly differentiate
into antibody producing cells and they're
waiting for that second signal to come.
And so these memory cells, um, uh,
are,
are a way that your immune system keeps
track of antigens that it's been exposed
to for even if maybe the plasma cells
that were producing antibody in response
to the initial exposure have
died and disappeared, right?
Memory cells are long lasting cells that
remember this exposure and can respond
very quickly on second exposure.
We talked about about antibodies,
we've talked about them a two weeks ago,
we talked about them in section
last week, uh, uses of them.
I just want to remind you that if you
looked at the population of antibodies
inside, uh, in your blood, for example,
the predominant antibodies
would look like this.
These are the class called
Igg there y shaped molecules.
They have a region down
here called the FC region,
and that is responsible
for effector functions.
And there's a region up here called
the antigen binding region and those,
and there's two copies of that region
and it's responsible for antigen binding,
right?
And so many the predominant number of
antibodies in your blood look like these
igg molecules,
but not all of them do.
There are different kinds
of antibody molecules, uh,
and not only the Igg,
but there are special
antibodies called Secretory Iga.
And these are highly
enriched in a mucosal fluids.
In the mucus lining of your gut.
You have the eye of other, uh,
a mucosal organs and they're
also enriched in milk.
So milk contains large quantities of
this special class of antibodies called
Secretory Iga. They also have
binding sites for Antigen, uh,
but and but they are sort of two igg
type molecules bound together by another
peptide chain.
And so imagine taking two Iggs,
turning one upside down and
then they're hooked together.
The advantage of this is that now you
have four binding sites for antigen
instead of just two.
And so these are better at binding to
antigen because they have more binding
sites on them.
It also turns out that there's,
they're made stable in these environments
like milk and mucus secretions because
of this secretory chain
which is wrapped around it.
And another important class
of antibodies is called IGM.
And the IGM is really five Igg type
molecules that are linked together through
dice sulfide bonds,
uh,
such that their fc portions are all
pointing in and their antibody antibody
binding portions are all pointing out.
So now you have a single molecule,
very large molecule with
not just two binding sites,
but with 10 binding sites.
And so this is a very potent
molecule for binding to antigen.
One of the things that I didn't mention
before is that when you get this primary
response and then the secondary response,
if you looked at the antibodies that are
generated during the primary response,
again,
we're only looking at antibodies that
bind to the particular antigen or vaccine
that we have used for the priming.
If you looked at the antibodies that
were present in the blood, for example,
you would find that most
of those antibodies are igm
during this initial period
of, uh, of antibody concentration rise.
Most of them are up the class igm,
igm antibodies are,
are produced on first exposure.
If you look later as the antelope,
as the antibody production
response matures,
some Igg is produced right?
So that in the late period
after initial priming,
you'd have a mixture of igm and Igg
and the blood on second exposure.
It's different that Igg is produced
predominantly on second exposure to an
antigen.
Okay,
so one thing I do want you to remember
is that igm class antibodies are the
antibodies produced on first exposure.
Why? Why do you think igm are,
uh, are produced on first exposure? Well,
one way to think about it as they have
more antigen binding sites and said
they're going to be more efficient
at neutralizing the pathogen on a per
molecule basis than Igg is. And so it's
good to get those produced more quickly.
Um, the memory cells which are
stimulated lead to an igg response.
And that's why Igg is
the antibody, uh, of, uh,
that is produced
predominantly after the boots.
But there is some igm produced also.
So let's talk about, uh,
about the polio virus vaccine.
Keeping those things in
mind. And, uh, polio was a,
is a crippling disease in many
cases. It affects, um, it also,
uh,
initiate it's infection through the gut.
It can be passed from one
person to another, uh,
orally and,
um,
infects first cells of your intestinal
system and then spreads to other cells in
particular spreads to cells
that are involved in the
neuro muscular junction and
can affect, uh, then, uh,
muscle activity or your ability to
move a voluntary muscles. And so polio,
uh, the disease caused by polio, uh,
can be a paralytic disease
crippling and in some cases can,
um, can lead to death if, uh,
if the disease progresses in certain ways.
And if we looked in 1950,
the,
this is the incidence of paralytic or the
worst form of poliomyelitis in the U s
was about 20 up per
hundred thousand people.
And this is mostly a disease
that would occur in children.
You would first get exposed in
children in childhood and then, uh,
at a point when you're
susceptible to the disease.
And so in a town that's the size of
new haven with a population of, uh,
of let's say 100,000 people in
just the immediate new haven area,
there might be 20 of
these, uh, uh, instances,
a very severe form of, of,
uh, polio per year, uh,
20 crippled children, uh, would
result. And so over the course of time,
this could have a very substantial
impact on the community.
And, uh, because it's past, uh,
by an can be passed by an oral route.
It's a disease that's very transmitted
in school settings where children are
together and uh, or childcare settings.
And so it was something that, uh,
parents before 1950,
we're very concerned about if a case
of polio emerged in the community,
the chances that it could spread to
other children or to your child, uh,
were high.
Um,
so great interest in this and
the early part of this century.
And so a group of scientists, uh, um,
mainly in Boston found importantly that
they could cultivate the polio virus,
the disease causing polio virus that
could cultivate it in cell culture.
And they found that certain cells in
particular epithelial cells from a monkey
kidneys were very effective
at propagating the virus.
So you would grow these monkey
kidney cells in culture.
You would add some virus to the culture
broth. The cells will become infected.
The virus would go through its life cycle,
and the cells would be basically little
reactors for generating lots of virus.
So you could make lots of
virus to study Jonas Salk,
who probably you've heard the name was
a physician who at the time thought,
well,
if we can make large quantities of this
virus than perhaps we can make it into a
vaccine.
And,
but unlike the cow pox virus vaccine
IA that we talked about before,
this is the real disease causing agent,
right?
So if you just introduced
this polio virus,
which you could make in
large quantities into people,
now you would be causing polio,
right?
So you couldn't introduce the live
virus in because that would cause the
disease, not just immunity. Um,
remember that the lucky
thing about, uh, about, um,
the smallpox vaccine was that an an a
naturally occurring attenuated form of the
smallpox virus.
Very Yola called back Sinia was found.
And so that was a naturally occurring
attenuated virus that could be produced
into a vaccine that didn't
cause, uh, the disease.
So the strategy that salt
used was to kill the vac.
The virus instead make a lot of the virus.
It has all of its antigenic
epitopes on it, but we'll,
we'll just kill it so
that it can't replicate.
And then if we inject it into people,
they'll be getting the real virus.
So hopefully their immune systems will
respond to it, like the real virus,
but it won't be capable of replication
because we've chemically cross linked it
so it can't go through its life cycle.
Right.
I'll talk about viral life cycles in a
moment and you'll see how that killing
works. So they, uh, they grew the
virus in monkey cell cultures.
They purify the virus cause you've got
to get all the other stuff from the, uh,
the cells.
You're growing it in a way they inactivate
it it by treating it with formalin,
which is just a formula.
It's just a mixture of formaldehyde
and formaldehyde cross links, proteins.
So you cross link all the proteins in
the virus and you make a particle that
looks like a virus,
but it can't act like a virus any
longer because it can't replicate.
And then they did preliminary studies
of safety and effectiveness and people
basically injecting it
into some test subjects.
Making sure that they didn't
get disease from it and uh,
and looking at antibody responses
to see if it worked. And it did.
So very rapidly a clinical
trial was started.
Now the problem or one of the challenges
with clinical trials of vaccines is
that you have to,
you have to enroll a lot of patients into
clinical trials because only a few are
going to get sick in any case,
right?
Only 20 out of 100,000 so you're treating
healthy people and you're trying to
prevent them from getting a disease and
you don't know who's going to get it,
right.
So you have to,
you have to test it by 10 by giving the
vaccine to a large population of people
and then watching and seeing if you've
reduced the incidence of the disease.
It's,
that's a very different process than
testing a drug where if you had a drug for
heart disease for example,
you would give it to patients that had
heart disease and see if you had an
impact. And you could do that with
a relatively small number, right?
If you're trying to prevent a disease
that only occurs at a rate of 20 per
100,000 people,
you have to give the vaccine to millions
in order to see if the number goes down
that,
does that make sense?
And so they started a clinical trial
and the clinical trial was designed such
that almost 2 million elementary school
children were given this test vaccine.
And you can imagine, uh,
that, that this is a,
this is a monumental sort of undertaking
and a number of different ways.
One is if you have to coordinate how
you're going to give this vaccine to 2
million children across the u s and you
want to give it to people in different
communities to make sure that it works
in all the subpopulations where the
vaccine is potentially valuable.
Um,
you want to give it to children because
children that are susceptible and that
that's the, that's where you would like
the vaccine to be useful as in children.
So you want to give it to them because
the biology of children is different than
adults. And so you need to make
sure it works in that population.
And they had to give some of them the
real vaccine and some of them a placebo
vaccine in order that they could really
tell if the vaccine worked right.
You have to have it placebo controlled.
And they did this in 1800
elementary school children.
So these are about eight year olds.
So imagine proposing a clinical trial
like that today where you had a test
vaccine that had been, that had been, uh,
that had been tested in a few P patients.
It's thought to be safe,
but we're going to give it to a million,
uh,
the test vaccine to a million or 2,000,008
year olds in the u s and see if it
works. Well, you know, that was possible
at this time for a couple of reasons.
One is people must have had an incredible
amount of confidence and Jonas Salk,
uh, and, and, and he did a good job.
And in preparing the initial studies
to show that it was safe. And two,
it gives you some sense for how a
concerned parents were about the risks of
polio in the community and how much they
wanted of vaccine to be developed such
that they gave permission for their
children to enter into this trial. Well,
the vaccine turned out to
be about 70% effective.
And as we'll see in section
today of vaccine does not
have to be totally perfect
in order to prevent
transmission of a disease.
Because when a disease enters a community,
it's spread from one person to another.
If you can block one of those
people from getting the vaccine,
you also stop from getting the disease.
You also stop all the people they would
have transmitted it to from getting a
disease.
And so one can stop the spread of disease
through community without being 100%
effective in each person who
gets the vaccine. And that's an,
that's an important concept.
And so it was, it was effective.
It was a rapidly than introduced
into general use. So I,
I taught at Cornell before Gail
and my, uh, my, uh, assistant, uh,
was a woman named Bonnie
at, uh, at Cornell.
And She was part of the clinical
trial, uh, that did this,
and they gave everybody
certificates after it was done.
So you didn't know at the beginning,
you knew you were enrolled in
the trial that gave you a shot.
You didn't know whether you were part of
the part of the real group that got the
test vaccine or the placebo group that
got the control and it turned out that
Bonnie was part of the control group.
So she got a certificate
at the end thanking her for
participating in a clinical
trial and also telling her to go get the
real vaccine because she hadn't had it,
uh, yet. Uh, so, um,
so this is real people who were
involved in these tests. Well,
this shows what happened in
the period after this, uh,
this vaccine was introduced
into the general population.
So that would have been in 1954.
This is a complex slide.
So let me show you what it is.
The Salk vaccine is also called
the killed polio vaccine.
And some people call it KPV.
Also sometimes called inactivated
polio vaccine. I, ve IPV.
Uh, but this is the vaccine I just
talked about, produced by Sulk.
And after the clinical trial, it was
rapidly introduced into the population.
So this curve here with the squares shows
you how many millions of vaccine doses
were distributed across the u s and so
this is hundreds of millions of doses
that were given.
And as those doses were given,
you look at the prevalence of polio
within the United States and it dropped
dramatically in the period
from 1954. This is these, uh,
these filled black bars here referred
to this access polio cases per hundred
thousand population dropped down to,
uh,
to only three or four cases, uh, by 1956.
And so this just shows as the vaccine
was distributed given to more people,
that prevalence of the disease
dropped dramatically. Well,
it also illustrates that one of the
things you do after you introduce the
vaccine,
you can't stop there.
You have to continually watch what's
happening with this disease in your
population. And one thing that
happened was that after 1956, 1957,
the number of cases were down, there was
a small bump here. The cases were up.
And this was of great concern because
the number of polio cases shouldn't go up
as the vaccine is being even more
actively distributed through the country.
So what happened,
this led this led people to go back
and look at the places that we're
manufacturing the vaccine,
to make sure that they were all
producing vaccine of the proper quality.
And it turned out that one of,
there were three vaccine manufacturers.
One of them was using the
procedure not quite correctly.
They weren't completely killing, uh, the,
the virus when they produce their vaccine.
And so some of these cases were probably
due to polio that was transmitted by
incompletely killed a virus that
was present in the vaccine. Um,
they fixed that procedure and after that,
uh,
the Kate day cases went down even more.
Now the,
the polio vaccine that sock
produced was very effective. Uh,
but it required a fairly large dose of
the vaccine and it had to be injected
into the arms of children. And, uh,
so there was some thought
that maybe we could do better,
particularly if we took advantage
of the fact that this is a,
this is a virus that's
easily transmitted orally.
And could you make a vaccine that
would be effective orally as well?
That would be a tremendous advantage,
especially in children who
don't like to get shots.
And if you could take your five year
old or your eight year old in to get a
vaccine where there was orally
administered instead of a shot,
that's a much easier thing to do. Plus
it makes it, as I talked about last time,
much easier to think about distributing
the vaccine around the world because
shots require skilled
medical personnel and,
and whereas an oral vaccine could
be self administered, right?
And so that means that it's easier to
take into certain kinds of populations or
remote parts of the world.
So a,
an oral polio vaccine was
developed by a man named Saban.
And what he did was took the polio
virus into the laboratory and,
and tried to make an
attenuated form of it. That is,
can I get the virus to mutate in ways
that it doesn't change its physical
structure much so it still
looks like active polio,
but it changes as disease
causing properties, right?
So change is disease causing
properties without making it, um,
a non immunogenic.
And he produced an oral polio
vaccine from an attenuated virus.
This was not a naturally occurring
attenuated virus as used in smallpox,
but a virus that was attenuated
in the laboratory, uh,
basically by propagating and in culture
and looking for that were formed as you,
uh, as you propagated this virus under
different experimental conditions.
So this is the, this is the
vaccine that you probably took.
The vaccine that's still most widely
used in the u s is the oral form of the
vaccine is used because of
the reasons I described.
Why would you maybe not want
to use the oral vaccine?
What are the disadvantages of using it?
Knowing what you know now,
any concerns about taking the,
taking the oral polio vaccine
instead of getting the shot?
Are there any features
that you'd worry about
Bobby?
It's a live virus,
which is actually going to infect your
intestinal system and, and reproduce.
And because it infects your sales and
reproduces your immune system responds
much more vigorously.
And you could imagine that you've got
virus that's propagating inside your cells
making more and more virus.
Your immune system really responds
well to that doesn't respond as well to
killed vaccines.
And that's why,
that's why the Salk vaccine has
to be injected at a high dose.
So it's more effective
because it's a live virus,
but it's a little bit more concerning
because it's a live virus as well in that
you trust that it's attenuated,
but,
but could it convert back to a very
old form or a form that caused disease?
It turns out that that hasn't
been a problem. And in fact,
another advantage of the,
um,
of the oral vaccine is that you
give it to children. They take it,
the vaccine itself, the virus
reproduces in their, in their gut.
And they can actually spread it to
other children in the same way that they
spread the disease. Right?
You've got children that are,
that are maybe at school or it
childcare and you ever looked at,
at children in the playground, they're
all over each other sometimes, right?
And they can spread
saliva or other fluids.
And it turns out that, um, that
if you give one child in a home,
the, uh, the, uh, oral vaccine,
you often have a protective effect in
other children in the home as well because
it spreads from one individual to another.
That's another advantage
of the oral polio vaccine.
Okay.
Well,
polio is not yet eradicated,
but there still are hopes that polio
could be eradicated. It's only endemic.
That means only naturally
occurring in certain countries.
And the World Health Organization keeps
track of what countries have cases of
polio and when they occur
and what the frequency of,
and so this is a map from a few years
ago and there are efforts that occur
occasionally. For example, this effort
that's described here from 2001 where,
um, where the World Health Organization
has a push. They say, we know where the,
where the cases are occurring.
We know what communities
still have polio within them.
If we do sort of really
gear up for a massive, uh,
immunization effort in those areas,
we could eliminate polio
from that community.
And in this way by by knowing
what communities it's in,
an acting on all of them at once,
you might be able to eradicate polio in
the same way that we eradicated smallpox
so far. Those efforts have
failed for a variety of reasons.
One is the resources that are
needed in order to do this.
The other is that some places
where the disease occurs, uh,
the governments are not stable or there
might be civil unrest or civil wars.
And that makes it very difficult to
orchestrate giving vaccines when there's
other things happening in the country
that are more immediate concern.
And there are some communities that are
frankly suspicious of western medicine
and don't want a, don't want people to
come in with their modern approaches.
And, and, and, and feed things to, uh,
to, uh, members of their community.
So there are still problems to solve
in doing this. Uh, but I wanted to, um,
show you, uh, so that if you're interested
in this and you want to keep track,
there's a, oops, there is a,
okay,
I'm going to get it.
There's a web site called Global Polio
Eradication Initiative and you can look
and you can actually look and see what
countries polio is occurring in and where
they are and how many cases
have been reported. Uh,
you can't see this too well,
but there's a map of the world here that
actually shows you all the individual
cases of polio that occurred
between this period of August,
2007 and it's cut off on the screen
February of Oh eight. And, um,
and this is the kind of surveillance
that's needed to really make an impact.
And this is why, uh, one of
the other ways where, uh,
where engineering approaches are
needed in order to, uh, in order to,
uh, solve medical problems. Like this one.
There's a lot of engineering they've
already talked about in terms of producing
quantities. The vaccine, producing
it reliably, producing it's safe,
distributing it and keeping
track, uh, requires, um,
a level of sophistication,
uh, that uh, maybe, uh,
you wouldn't have thought
about, um, initially.
Okay.
So that um,
yeah,
that slide is, uh, is on your, is in,
in the slides that are distributed.
If you want to follow on that website.
There's the picture that
I copied a yesterday.
So you see most of the cases are in,
are in central Africa and uh,
uh, in the region around India,
particularly northern India.
Okay.
Let me go back and finish up today by
talking about the life cycle of a virus.
And again, this is a, this is
a highly simplified version of,
of the lifecycle of a virus.
This might be a polio virus for example.
The example I've given here is
what is a virus that contains DNA?
Is it genetic material?
You know that some back,
some viruses use RNA as their genetic
material and so their lifecycle is going
to be slightly different than this.
HIV is a member of the family of viruses
called Retro viruses and retroviruses
all use RNA as their genetic material.
I'll talk about that at the end of the
lecture here. But here's a DNA virus.
It infects a cell.
Usually viruses have, um,
have certain kinds of cells they want
to infect or that they're capable of
infecting.
And that infection occurs because of a
ligand receptor interaction on the cell
surface where the virus itself is the
lie gand and it takes advantage of a
receptor that's expressed on
the cell surface. For example,
HIV enters cells of the immune system
by binding to a receptor called CD four.
All right. Um, and uh, you can these, uh,
these trope Isms or affinities of viruses
for certain cells are a well mapped
out.
Now the virus enters the cell and it at
breaks down and it breaks down into its
component parts. And I show two
of those component parts here.
One is the genetic
material in this case DNA.
And the other is all the proteins that uh,
that formed the structure of the virus
that a DNA gets replicated to make many
more copies of the, of the, uh,
of the viral DNA using host mechanisms
that is often using the DNA polymerase,
which is naturally present in the host
cell for its own replication. And these,
the proteins that are produced by
genes that are on the viral genome get
transcribed and translated in order to
make more structural proteins that are
needed for assembly of the virus.
The virus then can self assemble.
That is you've made a
lot of genetic material.
You've made a lot of
the structural pieces.
There has to be some way that
the virus can reassemble,
repackage itself into,
uh, into active forms.
And then that those active
forms are released from the
cell. Now sometimes those,
that release occurs without the
cell itself dying. In other cases,
the virus propagates in such high numbers.
That release is literally an explosion
of the cell and release of tens of
thousands,
hundreds of thousands of
new virus particles from one
individual cell such that
the cell gets killed in the
process of replicating the virus.
These released particles can now
go on and infect neighboring cells.
They can travel in the bloodstream to
s to infect cells at a distance and the
virus spreads throughout
a multicellular host.
Now what happened with the Salk
vaccine is that formaldehyde was used
formaldehyde cross-links proteins.
And so if you treated this
virus with Formaldehyde,
even if it was entered able to enter a
cell, it couldn't break down anymore.
And so its genetic material
wouldn't be released. And um,
and even if it was released,
the genetic material is also cross
linkedin so it can't be transcribed and
translated or replicated.
All right.
And so this is the stage at
which you prevent disease in, uh,
in the Salk vaccine in the Sabin
vaccine or the oral polio vaccine.
Now you have a non, uh, very lent a virus,
so one that perhaps does not reproduce
in such high numbers that you create an
overwhelming infection.
But one that still goes through its
lifecycle but is limited in its effect.
So that suggests. Now, if you think
about this even highly simplified life,
suggest some other ways that we might
use kind of modern technologies to
engineer new vaccines.
We've talked about getting lucky,
finding a naturally occurring attenuated
live vaccine is in the case of smallpox.
We've talked about killing the virus
by cross linking it, for example,
to make a uh,
a substance that looks like a vaccine,
looks like a virus but can't replicate.
We talked about attenuating
in the laboratory using
cell culture techniques and
what we know about mutating virus's.
One can also purify parts of the protein.
That is parts of the virus.
That is,
do I really need to deliver the whole
virus if the immune system recognizes only
small pieces of the virus and
mounts an immune response to that.
How about if I just take
these pieces of a virus, like,
like some structural subunit,
some piece of protein and
use that as a vaccine.
Now I'm not introducing any
genetic material at all,
so I don't have to worry about it
replicating because there's no genetic
material.
All I do is deliver the vaccine,
the particles.
Well,
this is an approach that's been used in
a variety of vaccines most successfully
with hepatitis B. So the problem is
where do you get these proteins? Well,
one way to get proteins,
and it was first used in hepatitis B,
is to find patients,
find individuals who are already
infected with hepatitis B.
And so hepatitis has already
infecting cells of their liver.
Their liver is actively making new virus.
It turns out in the case of hepatitis V B,
the way the lifecycle proceeds,
that the cells make too much of the
protein and not all of it gets assembled
into the virus.
And so if you look in the
blood of patients that are
infected with hepatitis B,
you find a lot of hepatitis
B surface subunits,
proteins without the nucleic
acids circulating in their blood.
So what if I collect that blood from
patients that are already infected with
hepatitis B,
purified the hepatitis B protein,
and inject that back into people?
That would be a sub unit vaccine because
I'm purifying a subunit of the virus
that could be injected and hopefully
induce an immune response and it turns out
that that, that that works. What any
potential problems with that approach
would you like to get that vaccine?
You've probably,
you've all been immunized for hepatitis B.
Would you be happy to hear that that's
where your hepatitis B vaccine came from?
It's okay.
Sounds okay.
But it does sound okay and it does work.
The danger is that it's being purified
from patients that have a disease and and
so you want to make sure that there's
not other diseases that are present in
that sample at the same time.
And the hepatitis B subunit vaccine was
produced at the same time that that HIV
AIDS was being recognized as
a problem in this country.
We did not yet have good methods
per screening blood to look for HIV.
We didn't have the Eliza technique that
we talked about in section a few weeks
ago.
And so there was great concern that there
might be other diseases that you'd be
passing on from unknowingly from this
subset of patients that you're isolating
the vaccine from it.
So that particular subunit vaccine was
only used in people that are at high risk
for acquiring hepatitis B.
That is people that work in healthcare
situations that are exposed to a blood
routinely as part of their job.
It wasn't used in the general population.
What was,
what the vaccine you got was produced
totally outside of people using
recombinant DNA technology.
And in that case,
we took the gene for
the hepatitis B protein,
took it out of the virus completely.
Okay.
Cloned it into a plasmid that plasmid
was expressed in a foreign host.
In this case,
it was expressed in yeast cells and yeast
cells were grown in large numbers with
this plasma inside.
They expressed the plasmid.
And so you made hepatitis B
surface antigen, not in people,
but in, um, in a cell culture where,
uh, where it was not normally formed.
And then that, uh, that sub
unit was purified and, and, um,
formulated into the vaccine the
kinds of vaccines that you and I got.
So this was an early example
of recombinant DNA technology
being translated into
a clinical product. Um, and um,
that's the vaccine that's
widely used in, uh, in, uh,
in practice now.
Okay.
Uh, another approach which
is still investigational and
that it's being tried for
many diseases but not yet,
not yet clinically used in any
particular one is maybe you don't need to
introduce a whole virus or pieces
of, uh, of a protein at all.
What if you took,
instead of using,
instead of going through the step of
isolating the gene per hepatitis B,
cloning that into a plasma,
at expressing the plasmid in sales,
manufacturing these cells,
and then purifying the protein product.
What if you just took that plasmid that
that contains the gene for hepatitis B
and you gave that directly to people?
Then you could get the hepatitis
B protein expressed in yourselves,
right? If we injected it
into a muscle, let's say,
and your muscle cells took up this plasmid
and now the plasmid started to do its
thing, which is replicate and
the gene gets transcribed,
then your muscle cells would
start producing hepatitis B,
surface antigen and your immune system
recognizing that's a foreign protein
would start responding to it.
And that concept is called a DNA
based vaccine are DNA vaccines,
so totally avoids the manufacturing
processes that are used to produce other
vaccines. You got a
manufacturer DNA. Instead.
I want to say a little bit about the cost
of vaccines because this is a part of
what makes it difficult to, uh, to, uh,
to accomplish what's usually our goal
in vaccine development, which is,
which is deliver the vaccine to
every population in the world.
But often vaccines cost a considerable
amount to produce the hepatitis B vaccine
I talked about before,
produced by recombinant DNA technology
is called [inaudible] of x, HB.
That's one version of it.
And if you or I buy it,
it costs $51 per dose.
You need three doses to be effective.
Why do you need three doses of hepatitis
B? Because this is not a virus at all,
but it's a virus subunit. Your body
doesn't respond to it as strongly.
Your immune system doesn't
respond to it as strongly.
And so you have to formulate it properly.
That is mix it with things
which make it more, um,
make your immune system
respond more strongly.
And you have to inject it multiple times
because the first blip that you get,
an immune response is not very high,
right?
You have to boost and often you have
to boost again in order to get a high
enough response to be protective.
So for any one of us, it costs 150,
$153, $156, uh, to be immunized. Now,
that is doable for us,
but that's not,
that's not affordable in many parts
of the world. And in addition,
this is just the cost of the vaccine,
not the cost of the doctor or
nurse who injects it into you.
So you have to figure
that cost in as well.
The CDC can buy this from the
manufacturer for a lowest lower price.
And when you hear about, about government
organizations distributing vaccines to,
uh, different parts of the world,
they're buying at a reduced rate,
but it's still not inexpensive, right?
Uh, measles, mumps, and rubella.
This is an established
vaccine also quite expensive.
And I didn't have the commercial price
for the chickenpox vaccine called Vera
Vax, but you can imagine that it's
even more than $50 a dose for that one.
So I just wanted to try to
put that in perspective.
I also talked last time about smallpox
and the perceived need to produce more
smallpox vaccine in the event that
smallpox used as a weapon in 2002.
So shortly after nine 11,
the government made a
contract to a company called
a canvas to make 400 million
doses of smallpox for $343 million.
So this is not cheap, right?
And the problem is you've got to make
hundreds of millions of doses sometimes in
order to have an effect on
progress of the disease.
And so even if the cost is small,
$10 a dose,
it quickly amounts to a
large amount of money. Uh,
there were some problems with that
deal and I just give you one, uh,
one a news report on that,
but you can follow it if you're
interested in spite of that fact. Um,
uh,
it turns out that vaccines are one of
the best uses of our money in terms of
extending the lives of population.
And this is old data now from 1995,
but I don't think it's changed very much.
And it asks the question,
how much do different public health
interventions cost per life saved?
And so we have a mandatory
seatbelt law here.
That means that you have to have
seat belts and all your cars.
That means people paying more for cars
because they have seat belts and you have
to enforce the law and all the
costs that goes along with that.
In terms of life saved
by that may measure,
it's estimated that it costs
about $69 per life saved.
So that's a reasonable cost to spend,
uh, for something like measles,
mumps, and rubella immunization,
which costs what I showed you before.
You can save so many lives that way,
that the cost of distributing
and producing the vaccine
is actually less than,
than the, uh, the, the, the
value of the life's that save.
So it's saves money. Uh, you, you're
saving money by doing it, not,
it's not costing you. And obviously
these are complex calculations, uh,
but I just want to point out that
and smoking cessation advice,
advice about not smoking to
pregnant women is another, um,
another very inexpensive lifesaving
intervention intervention things that we
think are good.
And I'm not advocating,
we don't do them like having radiation
admissions standards for power plants,
nuclear power plants and other power
plants cost a lot of money per the risk
involved, uh, with them. And on
this scale, uh, vaccines are a very,
a very inexpensive way to save lives.
Okay,
we'll stop there section this afternoon.
Uh,
we'll talk about disease spread through
populations and how vaccines impact that.